we worked in the Irish independence 22
years ago with Veronica Gere and I
remember very well the morning that I
got the call said that Veronica had been
killed and it was also part of a
gangland dispute so in some respects it
does sound like we're back 20 years and
it is shocking I think the intensity of
what happened last weekend caught
everyone by surprise
journalists occasionally get threats but
the level of this threat and the context
that makes it particularly worry I mean
why do they get threats what are the
gangsters fearful of well you know I
think when sometimes when people talk
about gang gangs and they give these
people nicknames they almost sound like
comic characters these are dangerous
people who trade in drugs which cause
misery and they make a lot of money out
of them and journalist asked questions
and dig deep and expose them and that
makes them uncomfortable and you know
the journalists in independent
newspapers have been very courageous but
will continue to be courageous and this
is an attempted silence I mean as we
understand it there appears to be a feud
going on between rival factions if you
like do we know who is issuing these
threats yeah I'm sure the Garvey have
suspicions as to who they are
independent news and media sensibly have
not said which you know which which gang
this certain sources are coming are
emanating from I don't suppose that
either gang have particular respect for
media or the rule of law but I'm not
going to it would be immediate
speculation to the source it is worrying
it's worrying for the journalists
concern and for their families it's also
worrying for many freelance journalists
reporters and photographers who work
alone and who do not have the support of
the big corporations
I spoke to seeming to management at
independent news and media they are very
supportive all media organizations will
of course be look at reviewing their
security we would be advising freelance
journalists and anyone who is worried to
talk to us to talk to the gardenia
corner or to their employers they yeah
but ultimately this will not be dealt
with by increased resources
and by community support me what happens
you have to provide bodyguards for
German journalists can't work with
bodyguards a journalist must work
independently and that includes working
independently of the police and this of
course it was a factor regularly in
ordinary London
Veronica Guerin is one of two
journalists employed by independent news
in media who were who were murdered the
other was marked no Hagen and Marc no
egg and detained police protection
Veronica Guerin refused police
protection many other journals have had
to do so because you cannot work
independently as a journalist while
relying for police protection and
finally why is this still going on
what's happening is it a failure by the
police is it just the way things are I
well I I think that's a very complex
question I think one of the reasons is
happening is there is money in drugs and
there are people out there who are
prepared to do anything to make money I
think there is a need for increased
Garda resources and I welcome the
comments by on t-shirt tonight well that
would be half have to be matched by a
commitment to resources and genuine
resourcing to tackle this once and for
all and you know we cannot tackle this
problem by occasional investment
followed by cuts in guard or overtime
followed by the torture of police
stations but that's only part of the
problem there is also a need at the very
basic community level for support among
people and that's gonna take courage as
well I wouldn't underestimate the
courage of that but it will not be this
factor will not be born without
community support an extra resource this